what do you want from me what else
compress my name is PewDiePie welcome
200 Emily wants to play well I guess
we'll have to play with Emily yeah Emily
wants to play they donated to the
charity that we did and I just want to
say how much did thank you very much I
really appreciate that that's very cool
so I feel like I
I owe them to play the game but I would
have played it anyway so don't worry
about it
here we go hello yes your pizza's here
oh my god I'm a pizza delivery boy I
always wanted to be a pizza delivery boy
finally a video what I want me to go in
here pizza Aidid anyone order pizza
I got pineapple I got new Gia
I got I think they want to kill me
hey this isn't money where the [ __ ] is
my tip over a month now we still haven't
found any leads on the bizarre death of
a local company the couple was found
lifeless in their living
oh I get it this is one of those YouTube
pranks Fouzi are you underneath the bed
Fuji oh that I would never fit
underneath there okay well I guess we're
done here
nope it's up for you why I don't know
where that came from
oh [ __ ] there's something there's
something over here Oh Jeff not if it
does Vista sorry not scared I'm not a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
who's screams at video games I'd be
[ __ ] dumb hello there clowny do you
have my tip well I guess 9
oh [ __ ] and a [ __ ] stain oh god this is
actually not creep I'm not scared with
my youtube channel
checkers Pizza what I'm not from
checkers
the flashlight is a piece of [ __ ] Oh
what just fell through the wall
what the [ __ ] was that supposed to be
scary
I didn't even flinch whoo let's do a
replay on that [ __ ] did I [ __ ] myself
yes I did but I did not flinch all right
[ __ ] that Clowney clowny you [ __ ]
hey that's she's she seems pretty cool
okay so now this time let's try and not
get too [ __ ] what do I do
it's a dead [ __ ] end oh god no
bali-ba hello your pizza's here
Oh Jeff did fun
[ __ ] all right I'm fine [ __ ] least
scary game I played in my life hey
what's that sound coming from hello
hello oh that's a fine ash over in the
pranking yeah you want something what am
i doing in the closet whoa whoa what
just happened what just happened what
did I do
oh my god that was the most random thing
I've ever seen in my life oh God
Emily's down here isn't she Emily Emily
and Bri what the [ __ ] just huh
oh god it turned midnight oh god it had
anything in turn to midnight yet I just
wanted to deliver pizzas okay so it hit
Midnight's I think we're fine now it's a
it's a little little too quiet for my
flavor but you know beleve you need a
fluffy scree
jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] [ __ ]
what did I do wrong
going home to Sweden oh she didn't [ __ ]
my face this time that's awesome really
appreciated that oh my god I can't
[ __ ] handle this game can I just go
home oh I can't escape either hey hey
put a lovely can peekaboo
what the funny dude
hey little girl what's your name my
sweet child you're lost ah did she moves
no ha ha did Lily jävla no no oh god I
got open this door okay just don't move
oh god she's so creepy oh god where am I
oh [ __ ] I don't like walking backwards
now because he's Oh Tom nee had invested
all day there stay away maybe I can trap
her are you [ __ ] [ __ ] i ah lock that
[ __ ] in alright now we're getting good
you shake it up my doors what do you
want what do you want from me
damnit flinch get a new door pick up
Emily's meds okay sounded like you did
neither of those you [ __ ] late oh god
what if I hello
Oh Edgar was scratching his legs I mean
oh my god you [ __ ] [ __ ] get a
[ __ ] life don't you have friends you
[ __ ] loser
but you watch YouTube all day I mean
whose usual chef bladder button then
smile :
god I'm sweating so much I didn't like
it
hey shut up
where's Stuart my own daughter she was
standing in our bedroom no it's night
staring at us that is [ __ ] up when
what the [ __ ] you're such a little
[ __ ] you are such a little [ __ ] yet
you think I can't don't know how to walk
backwards you [ __ ] [ __ ] there
must be something here my name is Jeff
that [ __ ] yeah you want a hug you know
huh guess what you're not getting one
cuz you're ugly ugly people don't get
hugs oh my god she's so close oh [ __ ]
did we do it
I'm sweating so much
I can't do this anymore too old for this
now that's right doll [ __ ] I destroyed
you that's right
got him Oh God not clowns or Santa